after after the convention
his approval among black voters right
we're talking about his racial division
in the riots
how much do you think it changed do you
think it went up or down i've kind of
given it away already
uh i think knowles i've been out of the
game for a little bit but you did lead
me there um
you know i tweeted about a year ago that
tr that trump's going to get 30
of the black vote that's an insane no
one in their right mind
would say that but i put these things
out there on twitter that's what i do
as a professional
the reason that the democrats are still
pushing
all of these race riots and stoking all
these race riots
because the rnc did a great job of
black and minority outreach this was the
you know it's so funny
in a way it was like almost pandering
you thought oh my gosh it's like every
black republican in the world is coming
and speaking at this thing
but they wanted to make the point the
democrats are calling us racist we are
manifestly not racist
the rnc i got to tell you i think it's
because of trump so wait was it in
florida i'm forgetting where the rnc was
all over there
oh so it wasn't phys that wasn't
physical either oh it was all
except they made there was a difference
here the republican convention came
afterward
and they learned from the democrats the
problem with the democrat convention it
was so
it was so dull there was no surprises
right
the republican convention was people
giving live speeches
to nobody and sometimes that was kind of
hilarious you know kim guilfoyle was a
very energetic you know she kind of got
memed afterward
um but you know people were passionate
and they were giving these live speeches
warts and all
there were some really amazing
highlights of it and and the difference
was that the democratic convention was
all vague it was all
trump's meaning and his bad the
republican convention
put up the victims of these riots
do you remember david dorn the black uh
former police officer who was killed
in the riots yeah his widow gave an
unbelievable speech it just totally uh
the parents of
uh kayla mueller who was abducted by and
killed by isis
they gave a speech specific about
obama's policies obama biden's policies
it was that specificity that really
really got you
and then trump's speech which went on
for 70 minutes
was all specifics it was i did this i
did that i did this we're going to do
this
we're going to do that after
after the convention his approval among
black voters right we're talking about
all this racial division in the riots
how much do you think it changed do you
think it went up or down i've kind of
given it away already
uh i think knowles i've been out of the
game for a little bit but you did lead
me there
um you know i tweeted about a year ago
that tr
that trump's going to get 30 of the
black vote that's an insane no one in
his right mind
would say that but i put these things
out there on twitter that's what i do
as a professional um i'm going to guess
that his support will tell me what the
support was going on before it was going
in and this is
this is mid-august so yeah very recent
numbers support was fifteen percent
fifteen
fifty percent approval yeah i'm guessing
it could it could be around thirty
percent
it hit it hit 24. already and by the way
that's only factoring in the first two
days that's not even factoring in
the last day of yeah it was just an
amazing surge because you got to
remember you say oh 24 that's not that
big
that's a 60 jump right if you go up that
many points over
over 15. if you go up nine points that's
a 60 jump well you know what it is you
can't
[ __ ] people forever yeah because
eventually
the masses wake up like the bullshitters
aren't that good at [ __ ] i think
that that's starting
to to become what what is real so it's
like if you're
if your whole narrative is america is
evil it was founded on racism
1619 projects systemic racism
everything's evil we're an oppressive
state the patriarch
all of these things yeah well then you'd
go all right if
all of those horrible things are true
yeah i guess
they had something to do with the time
before trump you know what i mean you
can't suddenly blame it all on trump so
in a weird way their their own
logic or their own um their own nonsense
the nonsense that they were peddling
about how evil we all are and how evil
the system that has freed more people
than any other country ever
the more they've peddled that nonsense
in a way it actually is telling you that
trump
isn't the horrible evil thing yeah
because it's like oh i guess
i guess obama was pretty evil he was
part of it and i guess biden was part of
it and that
nancy pelosi told me anything about
pelosi's pelosi she's
she's still ticking as far as i can tell
she's still still eating her ice cream
yeah but but you know what i'm saying
like if there if your whole story
is how horrible america is which i
suspect and has always been
which is what i suspect most of the dnc
what the convention was
yeah well in many ways you're actually
saying okay well then trump's not to
blame
for anything he's just a new guy you may
not like him
but he's a new guy who by the way at his
last uh
state of the union was talking about
all-time low black unemployment
and the congressional black caucus sat
there like this furious i thought that
was a good thing but
what do i know no that's that's right if
there is systemic oppression if the
system is rotten
then it's not can't blame this guy he's
only been doing it for three years well
you know speaking of these specific
yeah i do want to get into a little a
little kind of political celeb news you
got to be in on the gossip a little
bit of paper yeah yeah give me something
what's going on so who got destroyed
someone must have been destroyed
people got this people okay people got
destroyed i want you to tell me which
one of these is
not true oh god okay yeah i'll just give
you
i'll give you four okay and one
is not true one is
not true okay okay
jerry falwell has resigned because he
was found out to be
in a cuckold voyeur throuple
with the pool boy
that's the first one killian conway has
resigned from her post
at the white house candace owens
is pregnant jake paul's house
was not raided by the fbi
which one of those you're asking me i
got a double negative
all right so jake paul's house was not
graded yes
i feel like his house being rated is
probably true i don't really know who he
is
yeah he's getting hit in the nuts or
something on youtube i'm not totally
sure what he does
yeah um but okay so that that he was not
raided i feel like maybe he was raided
candace okay i'm good friends with
candace but i haven't spoken with her in
a month but i'm gonna guess
she could be pregnant so i'll take
candace as pregnant uh the jerry fall
cuckold thing is i think that's a little
beyond your imagination
so i'm going to say that that's true
you're going to say that the president
of a major i want to be very clear i
love liberty university yeah i love
liberty
i've met jerry nice guy from our
interactions yeah
but that seems somewhat possible i
suppose because i don't
picture you in coming up with that story
because you don't know what's going on
you don't know we're a good wholesome
guy so okay so that so falwell and
candace and what was the other one
killian conway is leaving the white
house that just seems like
two nothing for you to bring it up in
this so i'll accept that one is true
okay so i guess jake paul
[Music]
not being raided yes those are all i
mean you flip the knot obviously yeah
all of those stories are true all of
those jake paul's house was raided by
the fbi
so that that flipped okay let's just put
that one aside yeah okay forget that one
kellyanne conway stepped down okay
it's a bit of a scandal it's not a
scandal it's nothing she did it's that
her daughter made all of these social
media posts oh yeah i remember
anticipated right
and so uh kellyanne conway and
uh her husband george conway are
stepping back down from their jobs
kellyanne obviously at the white house
george conway from the lincoln project
yeah those great people so she is
stepping down it's too bad it's it's a
family issue i think it obviously it's
been heightened by the media scrutiny
and just how awful they've been to that
family
but that's pretty normal if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell